it's really tempting to talk about a
long-distance spaceflight it's easy to
say well why don't we go to Mars Mars
direct green Mars blue Mars red mars
let's go to Mars Mars is further than
almost everybody thinks it's hard to get
there and it's a long ways away you know
sometimes it's on the other side of the
Sun Mars is a long ways away it would
take with our best of our engine
technology right now realistically our
proven engine technology it's going to
take half a year just to get there and
then what are you gonna do when you get
there and then a half year to get back
and that really kind of highlights the
two biggest problems to me and one is
that you're going to leave Earth and not
get somewhere for a long long time so
the psychological impact of that is
going to be that there's nothing in your
window there's no huge stimulating
depressants view of our planet the whole
time to look at whenever you're not
doing something else and those crews on
the way to Mars are going to have a
schism with the earth within a week or
two I think because the earth is now a
distant visual memory and communications
are going to get slow enough that you
can no longer have a real-time talk with
anybody it's going to be we'll do a
video you do a video i'll send you an
email you'll send me an email but i can
never actually talk to you again and
that crew are going to become Martians
within a few weeks I think they have two
for the road psychological health they
will have to no longer be from Earth and
they all have to start viewing
themselves as being from somewhere else
and they're gonna have to develop an
identity so that's going to be a
different thing the other is how do we
keep them busy for a voyage that long if
you don't have a purpose to the day if
you don't feel like you're accomplished
something worthwhile then it's easy to
slide into all of the other mental
problems that that people who feel that
on earth are subject to and so we need
to somehow stimulate them the people
that are going that far on a regular
basis you need you need to be able to
get on a bicycle simulator and go for a
ride where you randomly turn left and
right it's just as you would if you went
for a ride on earth you need that's like
a holodeck you need that sort of
mental escapism more realism to be able
to keep psychologically healthy or you
need a really full suite of science and
work to do on board that actively
challenges and engages you the whole
voyage there and as a result I don't
think we're going to Mars for a long
time with our engines it would take so
long in order to guarantee the safety to
keep the crew healthy the costs are
going to be so prohibitively high the
frequency of flights is going to be so
low that I don't think anybody's going
to stand up to it until we go to a whole
nother level of engine technology or
maybe we can get to Mars in a month with
ion drive so that then then it becomes
practical then maybe you could withstand
it and show up and get back on one full
cycle or something it's it's it's a lot
bigger challenge than most people think
and that's not even talking about all
the technical challenges that face us